have that deeper connection with someone
so but they can't because they've slept
with too many people so I don't I think
it's like um
girls want to be with like the best that
they can do basically and so I'm
definitely punching
and and so the the thing is like the
more men that a woman slept with the
less likely he is the best that she can
do but but like look at I mean there's
times where like and and then it's like
she can't do as well because you know
he'll find out about three guys she
slept with
I feel like I have not wife in that one
I'm good it's true but that that's what
I think it is I think that the standards
get higher and I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing but obviously
when this awkward situation now where
like you know that that competition is
getting a bit unreachable for most dudes
um but yeah but I I do think like this
conversation is weird because it's both
like spiritual and like reality so in
reality the fact is we have those
objective levels right like you know
there are objective standards between
what you what a man is willing to invest
in for a long-term relationship on the
other side you should be able to kind of
Express Yourself freely and not not be
judged in that way because I don't think
every time someone sleeps around us
necessarily because they're there so you
need to kind of have some traditional
conservative opinion on oh she's this or
that I know a lot of women who can have
casual relationships and they know the
boundaries and I know a lot of people
who tell themselves they can have cash
relationships with actually looking for
something deeper and there's women who
are doing that but they're actually
damaged there's women who are kind of
virgins but they're deeply traumatized
you know it's not the world isn't that
simple I think that Nuance needs to be
there of like I agree so slapping things
on people you're right bro but how do we
create a filter to find out who's who
you get to know let me tell you how
because the world has done it for time
every with anywhere else in our lives
other than relationships everybody
follows the same rules credit score as
soon as you go to get a loan what's the
first thing they do they look at your
history when you go to get a job what's
the first thing you look at your history
when you get arrested and you make a
crime what's the first thing they look
at so how do you find their history
handles how do you have that yeah yeah
nowadays it's on your social media it's
everywhere
that's the problem like I think that one
of the best indexes I think one of the
best Industries like I think I think one
of the ways I think one of the best
Industries going forward is going to be
um erasing women's sexual Past online I
think that's gonna be like you want to
be rich the thirst traps you were
probably like
um there's traps you were posting when
you're 18 it's it it's a shame for you
in a way because you're paid to do it
but it's like I could see how that would
no like there's definitely times where
like I definitely don't do anything
extreme now it's more like well actually
I'm like quite invested in someone at
the minute so I'm not talking to any
guys but
um
is some things I have posted and I know
they're going to come back to like bite
me in the ass one day and I do really
regret that so yeah I can see what
you're saying yeah and I think people
would pay thousands of dollars to get
some of that [ __ ] that you twerking I've
literally been sent like 2K from one guy
just for conversing and like talking and
like talking I was like I'll have an
insecure about my nose he was like oh
let me send you the money for it and I
didn't send any news or like yeah it's
crazy you know
um okay you go and then go ahead can I
just say this may sound a little bit
barbaric but I say this to all my
friends and they hate me for it he's
probably gonna tell me off later but
like I feel like
um there is certain like some people are
just better than others like you can
just some people will just you know
whether that's looks or the decisions
they make and it doesn't mean that every
girl that has slept with you know loads
and loads of guys is traumatized or hurt
or you know she's trying to to forget
something sometimes it just means that
she makes really bad decisions and I
mean still a hoe though exactly that's
what I'm saying that doesn't mean that
she makes bad decisions and that just as
a whole that makes bad decisions
this is so stressful because what these
what he's like I'm sorry baby you know I
love your respect for hours
tell us would you describe it yeah you
gotta use a word to describe
one okay I'll just say she gets around I
don't know I've I've become she does a
tank I kind of reached this point of
like
avoiding being unnecessarily
disrespectful so so for me and I think
this happens a lot in the space of like
people get so obsessed with this
conservative Viewpoint of having to
judge people and I think people get a
kick out of being like huge like with
three people four years ago so you are
bam or if you don't do this then you
aren't good enough for these standards
XYZ and I get that I'm that is not wrong
at all but I think
eventually and I had a bad hinge there I
learned this like yesterday yeah well I
went off on her about like we were
talking and then she was obviously a
feminist and then we had that feminist
conversation and she just first date I
do I filter
okay if you if you have any of those
like you know those like all men are
stupid or my brother's dumb because he
wants to be in finance he's supporting
the patriarchy I was like all right so
your family so what would you you say
people thought you were like an [ __ ]
that kind of conversation yeah um and I
can afford to do that but essentially I
got kind of reverse traumatized because
you basically didn't say anything and
she was very intelligent one to the top
uni in London and I kind of realized
that traumatized me I was like well she
she really didn't talk she didn't like
normally they you know the delusions
come out and it's like this that and I
kind of realized that was just
unnecessarily mean I guess like you know
even if she didn't meet any standards or
she had any silly ideas about being you
know sexually liberated or having people
she slept with you didn't I didn't
really need to do that like you know I
could have seen the best in her and
assumed she was a decent person who
wants a meaningful relationship with I
think 99 of people are but instead I
went with the red pool stuff and you
know it you know so so that's why I'm on
this like do we have to call each other
learn better language there's a
difference she going up to a random girl
you don't know and calling her a hoe and
describing
yeah obviously in person like obviously
in person but sometimes even in a group
dynamic like I think I think we all know
what that is without having to be like
because we all know who is a derogatory
it's not respectful terms that's that's
why you wouldn't say it to someone in
person but I'm just saying we never have
this conversation about like simps like
thank you
yeah and and so it's like if I I don't
think it's derogatory to call a man a
Sim no it's not and I would do it I
don't think I think it is I think it is
terrible that's you like that's you this
like burning like putting your finger in
the sky but it's like if you call a man
a simp he might stop simping
no I think sometimes like that's how a
lot of guys in the red pill space get
started they called it but yeah most
guys I think I think most guys have been
taken advantage of by a girl they were
simping for at some time absolutely I
can name my hundreds yeah I know I know
I know I'm know I know a list of people
that are simping as hard as they
possibly can oh yeah I know a lot of my
sisters
stop simping
same thing with girls like if you start
getting called a hoe you might do it
less but not really do what you want
more of a like a it has a more of a
permanent kind of stamp like you don't
know I would say [ __ ] or something
yeah but you know what we all know that
if you call someone like a woman
you've changed
I don't mean to call you out but then
you come in and the first thing you said
like
that's a fun time fun time
to call herself my daughter's 18 and
there's no way I would be like Oh yay
you're a ho because it's fun you might
not hear it but she's probably doing no
she's what hey bro having sex she's
having no no not that and I didn't mean
that I mean just like
this song I don't remember though you
know she's not but it's like I wouldn't
as a mother to a girl be like oh this is
a fun term if this if it was a fun term
I would be okay with using it but it's
not a fun damn no yeah
it's the same thing I'm just a fan of
being honest and like Simpsons hoes are
hoes I'm not gonna change the lights
what I've noticed about women is that
the second they wanna
diss another woman so in your own world
forget men for a second when another
woman wants to degrade another woman
what's the first thing they call her a
slag you're a hoe you're a slag you're
this you're an app because they know
within their own group that is not the
category they want to be a flag you're
not going to get offended like if
someone calls me a [ __ ] or ignorant or
something yeah cool but if someone calls
me a slug or something I'll be like get
your facts straight I do yeah
if you slept with more than one person
someone can say if you're slack so
you're saying I do think that it does
just depend on the person like I have
friends that like they're 19 their body
count is like over 100 yeah 100 yeah and
they're proud hoes like they literally
call themselves how they call themselves
a slug they call themselves
like what she was saying I do think some
of my friends are like they have trauma
and they are damaged in a way where
like they don't under that's the only
way they can seek validation is from
having sex with men it's very unhealthy
but it's very exciting if they were if
they were like taught from a young I'm
not saying young young but like for if
they were maybe given the facts about
things like we spoke about like para
bonding or the the likelihood of divorce
and the likelihood of not finding
someone on a million do you not think
that they might actually okay fair
enough I [ __ ] up in the past you know
what what um statistically how many
people are growing up in one parent
families where they're not taught that
Dynamic of two parent households so
they're not taught
how to I'm just saying I'm just talking
generalization I'm not telling you
personally
um if like it takes that Dynamic so you
have an anomaly
I just don't buy it like when the girls
are like oh I didn't know I had no idea
like if you didn't know then your first
reaction when a girl pisses you off
wouldn't be a call or a [ __ ] like I
think innately we we know I don't know
what your parents did you know your
parents might not teach you these kind
of it comes from a lot of things I think
the women are blurring the line of the
word hoes or the women are in between
being a hoe and being married and that
space in between there is a dangerous
space for women to be because the ho ho
is like real hoes like for real that
know they come in and smashing everybody
in the room they don't give a [ __ ] like
you said they're proud hoes and they'll
let you know that they're a hoe and
they'll make it clear that we hoes and
we out here twerking and then the girls
who are married like you at the other
end of the spectrum have a different
perspective the women in the middle that
are single trying to get out of the
whole phase trying to get out of the
whole section that's why they blur the
line of like oh I'm not home I'm just
dating on this is just my face this is
my tattoo I think I think it's a mating
strategy though like I think it's just
like the top like women fight for the
top 20 percent of men five percent
whatever it is ten percent immense
attention and I think like there's a
group of women that know they can't get
their attention any other way it's like
either they're too far gone so there's
no way they're gonna wipe them so you
know what [ __ ] I'll just I'll just
signal easy sex easy sex easy sex and
I'll get their attention and that goes
down that goes down to insecurities that
goes into self-esteem I don't even think
it's self-esteem I think like the world
will just let you know real quick where
you're at I do I think I think it's like
I like no I think it's girls that are
punching that's true you know you might
girls I mean how many
how I mean Brittany Renner right
yeah do you know what it is no no she's
so far gone then no no guy's gonna watch
her right she's proud of him
that's what I'm saying but like she's so
far gone wait wait wait so yes yes I can
um so Brittany Renner um she's uh she's
no she's a publico
um so basically she's just been with a
lot of like athletes rappers
entertainers like that's she's like
known for sleeping with a lot of people
in the industry so much so she wrote a
book yeah and like she didn't use any
other names but people kind of put
together who they were and then she also
like posted videos about like how to
catch a baby off of an NBA player like
yeah okay no you know what is sad about
like public figures like this like no
hey do what you want to do Etc but I
remember literally being in secondary
school like 15 14 years old and like my
friends would get up her videos on
Instagram and they'd be like oh see so
like it is fine that my body can't exist
and it is fine I've had sex with this
many people like I don't care I don't
but sex is being so devalued in today's
society Society sorry but yeah like I
don't think it should be praised to be a
hoe I think yeah if you want to be
sexually free be sexually free you're
gonna find someone who doesn't care that
you're sexually free or they have a
sexually free past like just like we
were saying you accept people for their
flaws some people would but you're right
there's a simple dog I do think I do
think public figures like that is quite
a negative impact on Modern that's
that's simple it's not going to be the
guy you want though to jump in because
well you're saying they're like
about the way that Britney Runners put
out and no one really talks about what
comes after I think that kind of goes
back to what it was saying before where
the consequences of that behavior needs
to be discussed from those girls that
are doing that yeah
it's like it's fine I think you know
whatever your lifestyle fair enough but
I think just going around the real life
consequences of things is that I think
it's the real issue of like listen if
you want to do your you know your
promiscuous phase or whatever fine but
let me just tell you what happens to
people who do that in the wrong way and
let's not like dance around that but I'm
not gonna be like oh you slept with too
many people you're not good enough for
this but that is the question
that is the consequences I just think
I think no one's really shouting but
okay but I just think I just think shame
um like it changes your behavior the
same way like when I was at work and
those guys being like yeah like I would
not touch a girl over too they didn't
know like because I I carry weight well
because I'm tall and so I don't think
they knew how much anyways but
um it's like hearing that like brutal
honest truth made me change my behavior
and I just think it's the same thing to
an extent but as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible